senator there's been a lot of tension
here in Europe around the NSA
surveillance scandal are you worried
about how much that's damaged
transatlantic trust I worry a lot about
it obviously I think it's damaged our
relations and especially here in Germany
for understandable reasons and I think
the president took the first step with a
major speech he gave on the issue now we
have to have congressional hearings and
pass legislation are you satisfied that
real change is in store in the US I
think some changes taking place but we
don't actually we don't know how much
has been done so that's why we need to
have legislation and hearings the
foreign minister of Germany called today
for an international forum to discuss
these issues and really try to draw up
international norms isn't that the
better way to go rather than a no spy
agreement no I think that that's
probably a good way to go but my past
experience with international forum says
that they've not been real successful
first it seems to me that the United
States should act legislatively and make
sure that everyone knows the rules that
we're abiding by that's the object of
people's attention is what the United
States does because we have the
capabilities senator speaking of
international fora the Munich Security
Conference is the place where the reset
button was pushed five years ago what's
left of that reset it's sounding like a
lot of cold war-style rhetoric here
today well there's concern about
Ukraine's concern about Putin's for
other aggressive behavior
there's clearly a perception that the
United States is withdrawing from parts
of the world I think that is one of the
reasons why the President of Germany
made the statement that he made about
maybe graydon greater involvement by the
federal republic of germany in world
affairs may be necessary so look
tensions are high look at what's
happened in Iraq 96 American soldiers
Marines in six hundred wounded the
Second Battle of Felucia now the black
flags at Al Qaeda are flying over
Volusian that's hard to explain to the
families of those who sacrificed Russia
is needed to solve many of the problems
that are being discussed here at the
forum are you convinced there's any
prospect for real cooperation with
Russia going forward not unless the
Russians are convinced that we are
steadfast that we will take certain
actions such as missile defense and
others right now they believe that we
are we are very not very strong tell
still remember President Obama told me
but have tell Vladimir that I'll be more
flexible when I'm reelected that's its
we are we are almost rudderless as far
as our foreign policy is concerned
Senator John McCain thank you very much
for being with us